- Your show, "Who Do You Think You Are?"
I was so excited to do it.
Not only me but my mother was
very excited for me to do it.
And when I did it, I just
had no idea coz my family,
I mean all of us
especially in America
we're all mutts, right?
And there's so many different
layers to our background.
And I just had no idea what direction
and it was the coolest thing ever
to find out about Isaiah R. Rose,
my great, great, great grandfather.
It was like the coolest thing ever.
What's the coolest thing you've
ever found out on that show?
- The coolest thing?
- Yeah, just anything that
sticks out on that show for you.
- I have to say the thing that sticks out
since I started doing that show
was how much I was learning about history
that you don't learn in school.
That there are these personal
stories and experiences
that do not get taught at all.
And just like the nuances of history
that are really important
to understand the context
for people's lives.
So it's great.
And I'm glad you brought
it up because we are,
there's gonna be more.
- What can we--
- On NBC.
- Oh, on NBC?
- In July.
- Oh that's amazing.
- [Lisa] I know, I'm so happy.
- What can we expect?
Can you talk about anyone yet?
- Yeah, I can tell you
who's gonna be in it.
We have, we'll do six episodes.
So we'll have Allison Janney, Zach Quinto.
Oh, I knew that I would do this.
(all laughing)
Billy Porter.
- Oh wow.
- That's gonna be good.
Nick Offerman.
- [Kelly] I love him.
- Yes, Zach Levi and Bradley Whitford.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Yeah, yeah.
They're great.
They're unbelievable stories.
- Yeah, it's just really
cool to dive into that
and I never would've, and
I think just so you know,
it's a cool experience for like,
I just grew up with my mom.
Like I didn't even grow up
with my brother or sister.
Like I didn't grow up with any family,
like aunts, uncles, grandparents, nothing.
So to go into that show
and actually find family
is really cool for a lot of people
that didn't have that growing up.
You feel attached to something.
It's beautiful.
- Yes, you're connected.
You're connected to your roots
and you're also connected to
the history of this place.
- And I've always felt
like a leaf, so no roots.
So it was nice.